One of the occupational hazards of doing
a show like this is that my friends,
my family,
people who come up to me at the grocery
store and at Ikea and pretty much
everyone that I encounter on a day to
day basis wants to talk politics with
me.
Fortunately,
I love talking about politics and
talking to people about politics,
so I'm usually happy to engage with
people even when I'm picking out an ice
cream or testing out the pivot couch,
which is surprisingly comfortable and
easy to put together.
One of the things I've noticed lately
about our political climate is that
people are having a harder time tuning
out of politics.
Even briefly to talk about other things.
This is somewhat anecdotal in my case
particularly,
but I bet that it's happening to you in
your life to suddenly.
It seems like every conversation is
political.
Every discussion somehow gets back to
trump and yes,
your aunt knows exactly how to solve
America's healthcare crisis.
Even though she can't figure out how to
sync or IPAD on face value.
None of this is a problem.
I love.
The people who were largely apolitical
are now becoming more politically
engaged.
People are not only talking about
politics,
but in many cases reevaluating what
their beliefs are because of the upside
down world that we live in right now.
While everything may seem crazy,
I really do believe this time that we're
in right now is a rare special moment
when so many people are all doing the
same introspection about their beliefs
all at the same time.
Whether this will lead to more or less
freedom to more or less tolerance or to
more or less peace all remains to be
seen,
but without question.
We're in some pretty fertile ground for
change right now,
and by change I mean real societal
change,
not just hoping change.
One problem I do see attached to all of
this opportunity for change and
reevaluation is that people are becoming
consumed by politics in a way which
doesn't strike me as particularly
healthy for humans mental state or for
societies at large.
It's one of the reasons I'm a small
government guy.
I want a government small enough that we
don't have to talk about it that much
because it doesn't even have the power
to do too much good or too much bad.
There's a built tradeoff there.
Small government can only do so much.
The rest is up to the people,
so if you want government to do
everything,
you really can't complain when it does
all sorts of things that you don't like.
Well actually of course you can complain
about it at least until that big
government comes and takes away your
right to do just that.
So my message to you this week is let's
keep talking about all of these issues.
Let's keep staying engaged and trying to
change things for the better,
but at the same time let's not let it
consume us to the point where it changes
who we are.
Social media can be an awful catalysts
to the endless focus on politics,
which is why I've been trying to take
the weekends off and focus on the world
that exists in front of my face instead
of the one that exists in 140
characters.
When you are online though,
try to find some nuance between trump
derangement syndrome and Nazi frog
obsession.
Most people
are good and what pretty much the same
things that you do,
so let's keep growing that new center
and as long as you're here right now,
we're once again partnering up with
Learn Liberty this week and we've got
author and director of the philosophy,
politics and Economics Department at
Duke University,
Dr Mike Munger.
We're going to talk politics,
philosophy,
economics,
and much more watch and learn unless
it's the weekend.
We're continuing our partnership with
the fine folks over at learn liberty
today and joining me is an economist and
author and a professor of political
science at Duke University.
Dr.
Mike Munger,
welcome to the Rubin report.
It's great to be here.
That introduction just makes it sound
like I'm confused.
I think it's probably right.
I thought it made you sound very
professional.
Well,
I.
I have.
I have several disciplines that I try to
contribute in.
Yeah.
What we're going to talk about those
several disciplines,
but first let's just talk about
political science because I was a
political science major.
Explains a lot of good or bad.
Oh good.
Okay.
I like to think that I'm one of the few
people that's using political,
a political science degree actually to
talk about politics and political
philosophy.
So my first question to you would be,
do you think that political science
right now is sort of needed more than
ever just to understand the basic
philosophies behind so much of the
craziness that we see in public
discourse these days?
Well,
for two reasons.
One,
political science studies engineering,
but it studies engineering of rules and
we tend to have this idea that what we
need is better people.
We're probably not going to get better
people,
but we may need is better rules.
The question is how to try to do that.
The other thing political science does
is look at some of the ethical questions
that have plagued human beings for the
last 3000 years.
So I see political science as being a
kind of ideal liberal arts degree that
combines an analysis and ethics,
but so of course I think,
and I,
I would,
I'm a political science professor that
we need more political science,
but I really do worry that people just
think,
well,
we can ignore the constitution of the
living constitution will change it to
interpret it the way that we want it.
We don't understand enough about rules
to be able just to change it willy nilly
and have it turned out well.
So I like what you said there about,
uh,
that we can't change people that much.
A lot of people seem to think that
that's what politics should be,
right?
We should actually change the way your
opinions are about very personally held
things through public college or choose
the new Messiah.
Every time Barack Obama was going to be
the new messiah.
He got a Nobel peace prize after he'd
been in office for seven months.
So the emphasis on this next person's
going to be the one and you see it
worldwide.
But it's a little surprising to see the
u s that come to it also.
Yeah.
So as a,
uh,
you do consider yourself a libertarian,
right?
You ran as a libertarian,
we're going to get to that and I am
certainly a libertarian and in the that
I am not a Republican.
Okay.
And I want to unpack the differences
between that and talk about sort of the,
the ever changing label thing,
which is sort of becoming meaningless at
the moment.
Um,
so with all the political philosophies
out there,
do you sense that some of the freedom
stuff is taking root right now?
Because I think to me,
things are going crazy right now,
but I sense that liberty reason,
getting back to some of the
constitutional stuff,
I do sense people talking about it a
little bit more now than perhaps two
years ago.
Well,
right.
I had a bunch of colleagues who after
trump was elected or colleagues at Duke,
so political science professors and
other people on the left who would come
into my office and sheepishly say,
you know,
you were right.
All this stuff about we need to worry
about the constitutional powers of the
president.
When George W Bush was president,
they were worried with Barack Obama.
They say,
you don't mind so much as long as my guy
is in charge.
That's the point.
Guy Won't always be in charge,
so what you might want best is a
dictator that you can pick.
Right?
That's not how it works.
That means that we have to have rules
and it's very frustrating.
The constitution builds in conflict,
and Barack Obama in many ways was a
terrible president in trying to
negotiate things with the congress.
He would prefer to go make speeches.
He liked that Messiah thing.
So I.
I do think that a lot of people on the
left are much more worried now about
sort of traditional constitutional
protections of freedom of speech and
about the separation of powers.
So the number of them have actually
said,
you know,
those federalists papers really
interesting,
aren't they?
Yes.
Welcome back.
Yeah.
So when George W dot Bush was signing
executive actions,
I assume you were basically against them
when when Barack Obama was signing my
assume you were basically against them.
I assume.
I assume you're not thrilled right now
with the amount that that trump has
done.
But that's really interesting to me that
your colleagues on the left are suddenly
gone,
oh,
now I get it.
You know,
we have people on the left now fighting
for states' rights because they don't
want the feds coming in and closing
sanctuary cities,
which I think is what a phenomenal flip.
I can't help but gleefully reminding
them,
you know,
you told me that was code for racism,
but now you're for state's rights
because you're worried about medical
marijuana.
You worried about same sex marriage,
states' rights.
It's true.
Was misused by advocates of segregation.
That's absolutely right.
Hitler was a vegetarian.
It doesn't mean that all vegetarians are
Nazis.
It doesn't mean that all state's rights
people are racists.
States' rights is an important part of
federalism and it means that we can
accomplish some things in the states.
So I have this conversation all the
time.
On the show,
but also privately because I'm a big
states' rights guy and and what people
will say to me sometimes even just the
conversation that is happening this
weekend,
someone was saying to me,
well,
I just don't trust that the states will
do the right thing,
that the southern states will do all
these backwards social things or all
that stuff.
Now had many people on here,
including a Randy Barnett who I'm sure
you're familiar with.
You talked about the foot vote and that
you should leave states and take your
economic value and your personal value
and your family and move somewhere else
in that.
That's wonderful.
And your ability.
That's the beauty of America.
Do you think that's a sound enough
argument for states' rights?
Well,
it,
that you can just pick up and go it.
It has,
it helps a lot.
It takes a while to do that.
Um,
I guess I would argue for the way that
we've elaborated states' rights,
which is we take the first 10 amendments
to the constitution,
the bill of rights,
and we apply those also to state laws
through incorporation,
through the 14th amendment.
So there are limits on what the states
can do,
but other than that,
yes,
the states can have all sorts of
different things and the ninth and 10th
amendments both reserved a bunch of
powers to the states and that I think
the expansion through the commerce
clause and we really sort of getting
down into the weeds,
but the expansion of federal powers at
the expense of the states has been one
of the catastrophes in constitutional
jurisprudence,
and I hope we'll go back in the other
direction,
but it doesn't seem like that president
trump's appointments seemed to be more
like a 10th amendment skeptics.
Right?
Well,
even just in the last week,
you know,
there's some.
It's a little confusing what the truth
is,
but it sounds like sessions may go after
the states because of medical marijuana.
These are the things that I just simply
don't understand.
If the Republicans or conservatives or
the trump people,
whatever that is,
wouldn't you want to take a stand that
would.
That would make some logical
consistency.
You get decent liberals to go,
yeah,
you're doing the right thing.
Well,
because that would mean that you would
be operating on principle and not
politics,
and I guess I had hoped and I'm now
disappointed that our republican friends
have not done that.
All they've done is what they decry it
in others,
when Obama was president,
okay,
now we're in power.
We'll do all this stuff that we rightly
criticized Obama for doing.
That means that you have no principal at
all.
What does that tell you about power in
general like that?
The second day get this and it's still a
little unclear to me what sessions is
doing about the medical marijuana thing,
but if he was to do anything other than
respect states' rights,
it shows me that once you have power,
you just some more power.
I think it's.
It isn't inevitable.
There used to be a norm of deference to
the constitution and to some extent of
forbearance or toleration,
so you know I'm Catholic.
Clearly I think that that's the correct
religion.
All others are mistaken.
I also think that you get to want
whatever you get to believe whatever you
want.
It's that,
that second norm of toleration that's
being wiped away and we're going to end
up just being a bunch of competing
interest groups,
so I don't think it's inevitable that
power is so seductive,
but there if if other people,
it's like standing in line.
If a bunch of us come up to something
and there's more of us than can get
through it,
we just automatically stand in line,
but if somebody cuts in line,
you say you can't do that.
What if a bunch of people cuts in line
the line breaks,
so our are the norm of toleration that
we actually require that this sense that
it's wrong to do this just because it's
wrong.
Even though I have the power that's
breaking down and I don't think that
institution can easily be rebuilt.
Yeah.
Do you see that breaking down in sort of
every facet of public life right now?
Like for a moment before we started,
we were talking about the media and it
seems that mainstream media and norms
are crumbling and we have activists,
activists that are now masquerading as
journalist.
This is a huge problem.
Well,
for a very long time in a number of
different professions that were sort of
guild rules,
that is I have to act as a professional
or,
or I will lose the respect of my
colleagues and that respect comes from
doing things the right way.
Not taking positions that are correct
according to the liberal or Conservative
catechism.
It's doing things the right way.
It's actually doing real reporting.
Uh,
instead,
both sides are substituting what Stephen
Colbert called truthiness,
which is there's an essential truth that
exist irrespective of the facts.
And the facts are not evidence there
examples that makes a world of
difference.
You're coralling with my examples.
I have other ones.
Well,
no,
if you say something that's not a fact,
that means you're not a professional.
You should be embarrassed.
That's what we're losing.
Is those norms of professionalism.
Where do you think that started or when
do you think it's fair to the most
famous incident was dan rather and some
producers at CBS with the letters from
the Alabama national guard about George
W dot Bush.
And the letters were provided by
someone.
He said he'd found them in some files,
but when you looked at him,
it was pretty clear that they couldn't
have been done on an IBM selectric
typewriter there,
proportional font.
They had the wrong size footnotes and
they should've backed off.
They don't made a mistake.
They didn't.
They doubled down and said,
well,
but there's an essential truth here,
and so what happened was,
and this is the origin of the pajamas
media,
the CBS producers said something you
thought was true that turned out to be
true in a way he didn't expect,
which was,
who are you going to believe?
CBS News or some guy in his basement
wearing pajamas?
Well,
it turns out that the guy in the
basement wearing pajamas is pretty good
at fact checking and so that it didn't
start there,
but that was a catalyzing moment where
people said,
I mean,
CBS News,
Edward r Murrow,
this is as,
as professional was.
It gets and they substituted their own
ideological judgment for any sort of
concern about facts.
The guy in the basement seems to be
getting more powerful these days.
Do you view that as a,
as a net good.
The powers asymmetric,
we cannot discover truth.
What we can do is impeach false hood,
so the guy in the basement is pretty
good at checking and seeing if there's
something contradictory to a claim that
you've made and what that means is that
no one can believe anything now because
there's always someone who's checking on
it and saying maybe making this up.
They're,
they're,
they,
there's a quote in a tweet and then it's
to a link and they just assert something
and it becomes a fact.
This is,
this is a problem.
So it's a terrible,
a terrible problem.
So then how do you as as a political
science professor at someone that's
trying to frame this for young minds,
how do you give them something that they
don't walk out of your class at the end
of the semester and go,
Oh man,
we're,
we're screwed.
Or maybe they do.
And that's how you eventually fix
things.
Well,
I,
I want them to walk out of class saying
we could be screwed.
We have an obligation to try to act
against this.
And one of those obligations is to do
the right thing even when it's not in
our self interest.
And so,
uh,
one of my students from a while back
from duke is a guy named Brendan Nyhan
at Dartmouth College who writes a lot
about this sort of problem.
And so I think if you,
if readers are interested,
if you look at Brendan Lyons work on
this question of I think there is some
hope in this direction,
but if it's gonna we're gonna have to
enlist the aid of more of the mainstream
media.
And the problem that you have is you may
just lose.
The ratings were,
yeah,
if you're not interesting and
provocative is,
have we already crossed that point?
It seems to me that the election got us
to sort of parody between the online
media and the mainstream media.
And like that night it sort of became
equal.
And now at this point I think the online
media actually has more influence and
that's sort of why the click style and,
and some of the stuff that we've seen
with CNN over the last couple of weeks.
That's why it's gotten crazier because
they're.
They're just grasping for.
For the last bit of relevancy,
let's put a more hopeful spin.
This,
it is true.
Remember we talked about states rights
were misused by segregationists.
Well,
it's true that some of the power for
curation of the mainstream media was
misused and when we no longer trust
them,
but it's much easier now to produce
content and I it self serving,
but your show is a sign that people are
actually willing to spend more than
three or four minutes or 140 characters
and try to understand things.
So there is this desire to know if not
the truth,
at least the nuance of the different
claims and the ability to leap frog.
You can just put something up on
Youtube,
you get subscribers and to some extent
that's going to determine something like
ratings.
So you don't have to go through these
institutions that until now have meant
that only a relative few people could
participate in the conversation.
But do you fear the wild west factor?
The I do the best job I can,
but people sometimes say to me,
Dave,
you're the only person I trust,
and I go,
man,
this is a huge problem.
I'm I'm doing the best that I can truly
ready to transition.
Yeah,
and the wild west actually wasn't that
bad in a way.
There's a book by Terry Anderson and PJ
hill called the knots of wild wild west.
If they talk about the California gold
fields and the fact that people came up
with ways of allocating property rights
and adjudicating disputes,
so for a little while,
yes,
it was bad,
but people realized,
wait,
this sucks.
We can do better than this,
and they organize themselves.
So I think within five years we're going
to look back on this.
Time is a time of transition,
but not as a time of catastrophe.
New institutions are going to emerge
because the ability to curate and
provide news that people can rely on as
much fun as it is just always to be
outraged.
I think we're going to come up with new
institutions because the stakes are too
high.
Yeah,
and I hope we do.
I mean,
as someone that's an outsider for that
crumbling thing,
which I think it should crumble,
I do want some new institutions to exist
because otherwise we're just going to
filter ourselves into,
into total distance from each other.
We're in a way the the catastrophe that
is the trump administration,
it means that a whole lot of people.
It happens that the editor for the
weekly standard,
Bill Crystal is a friend of mine.
His daughter went to Duke.
I know a fan of trump.
Not really a fan of trump in terms of
conservatism.
That should be great.
He's got a Republican Congress,
Republican president,
but he's saying no principals.
More important than power.
So for a libertarian,
and obviously you can bill is not a
libertarians but he's not.
He's not a libertarian but.
But for a libertarian,
do you do think trump has been a
disaster?
Because I can see arguments that make
some sense libertarian wise in terms of
some of the state stuff and some of the
taxes,
stuff that kind of makes sense on a
traditional libertarian or even
conservative side,
and then some of the bigger government
things that don't make sense.
I think jeff session is the worst
presidential appointment of my lifetime.
Wow.
He's a disaster.
And that alone,
the sort of the no state's rights,
no fourth amendment.
Jeff sessions is terrible.
Uh,
I have some friends including Walter
Block at Loyola University in New
Orleans who is hoping that trump will be
something good on foreign policy.
I think you could make that argument.
I don't think that.
I think trump's inability even to
consider rule of law and the
constitutional restrictions on the
presidency.
It make even worse.
The slide that we've been in for an
expansion of an imperial presidency.
So I,
I worry that all of those bonds are now
going to be broken and we're going to
look for the big man,
the Messiah,
and we're just going to trade back and
forth between different visions of that.
And that can never work.
Yeah,
and that goes exactly to where we
started this conversation about looking
for that and say,
do you think that our institutions are
actually strong enough?
I mean,
I'm believer that these institutions
still have enough power that if trump
was to do something truly illegal or
truly overstepping executive authority,
but even though the Republicans Control
Congress,
that there were,
that we still have enough juice left in
the system to take care of that.
So that I think would sort of mitigate
some of my fears about him for sure.
Absolutely.
The system is pretty strong in a way.
So James Madison in federalist 51 said
that the structure of the government
should be such that ambition is made to
counteract ambition.
So you can be Republican member of the
Senate,
but you look in the mirror,
you see your God,
man,
I am a bad ass.
I have the power of the Senate here or
the president is trying to use executive
orders.
I don't like that much because it makes
me less powerful as a senator and so a
number of people in the Senate,
I think we'll use madison's ambition
must be made to counteract ambition,
insight to limit trump at some point.
Yeah.
So as a guy that I,
I can tell,
obviously you're not a big trump fan,
but you still trust in the system.
What do you make of when you hear
someone like maxine waters constantly
saying,
we're going to figure out a way to
impeach him,
you know,
like we don't know what it is yet,
but we're going to get there.
That to me,
that is almost more undermining of the
system than the excesses that trump may
or may not have or may or may not be
doing at the moment.
I agree with everything you said except
almost.
Oh alright.
It is more undermining of the system so
we don't have a parliamentary system
where a vote of no confidence is enough.
It takes high crimes and misdemeanors
and I was actually proud of the American
system in 1998 were for no good reason.
Bill Clinton.
There's a lot of problems with Bill
Clinton,
but he was impeached and the sentence of
this is stupid.
Well,
I think that that would happen again.
There's the Democrats were very upset
when there was a movement among
Republicans to say we should impeach a
Barack Obama.
So I think that this may just be
background and the,
the nice way to interpret it is it's a
way for Democrats to raise money from
their base.
They don't actually mean it,
but it's just red meat out there.
Right.
Which is also pretty horrible.
But just saying it.
Yeah.
Means that you're undermining the rule
of law.
You're actually doing what you say
you're upset at trump for doing.
Yeah.
So is there anyone in politics right now
that you look at and you go these guys
basically on board with,
with the principles that I believe in.
I mean,
it won't surprise you to learn that.
I admire Rand Paul and I actually liked
the Gary Johnson.
I really.
Let's talk about him for a little bit
lower.
Let's just talk about him within the
framework of libertarian politics.
I've had him on the show.
I spend time with him about a half hour
before we were on air.
I think he is a totally lovely guy
really,
and I enjoyed talking to him and I could
see us being friends actually,
but the candidacy was pretty terrible.
It was the greatest ever.
It was three times as much as we've ever
gotten before.
We got three percent.
That's amazing.
That's enough for ballot access in many
states.
But do you think that might've just been
a function of disgust with the other
two,
that sort that gary himself,
that unfortunately just seemed ill
equipped to be up there and have enough
of a command of the issues and by the
way I say that with total sympathy for
him because there was nothing he could
do to get in the news except flood.
They would only talk about it when he
floods,
so he was in an unwinnable position.
He is so much better than anything else
that we have had and I mean I'm actually
a libertarian partisan.
I ran for governor of North Carolina in
2008.
I did not win.
What we're going to get to that.
Well,
I campaigned with Gary Johnson.
I got,
I got to know him pretty well.
Yes.
He flubbed that.
He was tired.
He made a bunch of mistakes and that's
what the media emphasized.
It was really important that he got
three percent and in fact,
if you were to look,
suppose you strip away the party labels
and you're a visitor from Mars.
Yeah,
well there's this person who has been a
secretary of state and has experienced
as a senator,
and then there's these two people who
were multiterm governors have pretty
mixed states and then some psycho person
in real estate.
You don't think.
All right,
those are the libertarian candidate.
So I.
my question would be compared to what I
thought,
Gary Johnson did a great job.
He does.
He did the best libertarian candidate
has ever done and he gave us something
to build on.
Did I cringe at the Aleppo incident?
Of course,
yeah.
Well that's the thing I.
In August I,
I endorsed him basically with the idea
of let's get the guy to 15 percent so
that at least for one debate,
because we know the Democrats and
Republicans control the debates at least
for one debate because they'd never let
them in in second line,
but at least for one,
let's hear some of these law limited
government ideas and unfortunately there
just wasn't enough juice there.
But you know what I'm hearing you and
maybe I will ease off him.
A little question is compared to what
you got three percent.
The best we ever did was one percent.
All right.
So then what does that mean to you?
Is the,
is the future for the Libertarian Party
and do you think that a third party
actually,
ah,
if,
if that three percent means something to
you,
do you think that that means it could be
six percent in 20,
20?
Could it,
could it be really impactful in 20,
23rd parties in a system of first past
the post,
which is what we have.
You're always going to have two main
parties in a first past the post system,
but the positions of the parties will
depend partly on the pressure that's
bought brought to bear and if you have
someone who can participate in debates,
particularly at the state level,
you can remind the two state sponsored
parties of the things that are in their
platform that they're leaving out,
so I don't think a third party is going
to win,
but what I care about is the policies,
not the face of number.
I care about rules and not the people.
So if the two state sponsored parties
are obliged by opening up to the
scolding wins of competition and they
have better policies that that's what I
hope that the third parties can do.
Yeah.
I hear people on the right all the time
say,
well,
if we back a libertarian,
what you end up doing is splitting the
vote on the right and then you help
people on the left.
How would you explain to somebody that
may not matter and maybe that has to
happen?
Well,
you only get one vote and sometimes
people do advocate what political
scientists call voting.
The Lote lesser of two evils.
If you vote for the lesser of two evils,
you're certainly going to get an eval,
right?
The only way to waste your vote is to
vote for a candidate you don't actually
want,
and if you vote for a candidate that you
do want,
that's going to give a signal to the two
state sponsored parties that we don't
find this to be acceptable so that all
your votes are wasted.
They don't determine the outcome.
Now,
what I get then is conservatives
particularly saying,
what if everyone thought that way?
Ah,
agenda,
you are so your vote affects thousands
of others.
No.
You have one vote.
You can choose to waste it,
or you can vote what you actually
believe and try to send a signal.
Yeah.
Which I think would be more important
than just throwing it away or I would
think that there.
I think we've gotten stuck in this
lesser of two evils as the two parties
have gotten more and more evil.
Yeah.
Do you think part of that also is that
the whole system now,
when I say the system,
I mean our political system and our
media system,
there's only a certain type of person
who would run that and now we can talk a
little bit also about your 2008
campaign,
but that it would take,
you know,
the idea,
the idea of having to deal with what
your family will have to deal with.
They're going to track down every email
that you ever had an affair or whatever
it is.
Just all of that nonsense.
You're only gonna get a certain type of
person that wants to do this and adding
that.
Basically.
Good decent people will self select out.
I hear this all the time.
Every time I see somebody I talked to
somebody that I think should be in
politics,
they wouldn't want to subject myself to
that,
but many guests here that privately.
I've said,
you want to run for something and
everyone.
Nope,
never.
There's really two problems.
One is the process of running is very
difficult,
takes a lot of time and you constantly
have your motives questioned and it's
psychologically very difficult.
The other problem is if you win,
you have to serve and a lot of people
that are really good at things are
really good at things.
They're doing something else,
so you have to be the sort of person who
that.
I don't want to say too much about
Donald Trump,
but who just thinks of yourself as being
essentially infallible.
And the problem is we as voters validate
that.
So I found often in debates and talking
to people,
voters would ask a question about some
policy and I said,
well that's actually complicated.
That's something experts disagree about.
Here are the two arguments and you can
see their eyes glazing over and my
opponents would say,
I know exactly the right thing to do and
here it is.
And then they would say something
stupid,
but that wins.
I know what to do is always going to win
over.
This is heart.
Yeah.
Which is also a great argument for small
government to admit it.
Every now and I don't know what to do,
so maybe we shouldn't be,
uh,
you know,
passing just things that are going to
completely change the system because the
truth is nobody knows what comes out on
the other side and the fact that
something is a problem doesn't mean that
there's a solution.
So the,
I,
I call that the,
we should do something problem x is a
problem.
You're right,
we should do something.
Why is something therefore we should do
y?
It doesn't follow the fact that
something should be done,
but then they'll say,
well,
you don't care about x,
so of unemployment and poverty are
problems.
And so there are these things that we
should do.
Right?
And I said,
well,
those things won't work.
Oh,
you hate pork.
And it's almost impossible to,
to extricate yourself out of that.
Right.
Sorry.
So you ran as libertarian candidate for
governor of North Carolina in 2008.
So first off,
within a year,
I can tell you're a real politic person.
Why not just run as a Republican?
Which would have perhaps given you a
better shot,
just just start.
Just in the reality of,
I live in North Carolina.
Yeah.
Are Democrats or Republicans or
Republicans or Taliban?
They're there.
They want Sharia law.
Now it's Christian Sharia law.
So this is the real Christian,
right?
I would have come in eighth in a seven
person primary if I had run as a
Republican.
So there,
there really is no constituency in North
Carolina among the Republicans for my
view of conservatism.
But if the,
if the Democrats or Republicans,
why not run as a Democrat then the,
I considered running as a Democrat,
but the Democrats have had a machine
that controlled the state and it was
clear who the nominee was going to be.
I also,
my the reason that I ran was my
objection to North Carolina's ballot
access laws.
We have some of the most restrictive
ballot access laws in the country.
Uh,
if coke and Pepsi could decide on any
soft drinks,
there should be.
They would say to the Republicans and
Democrats actually get to do that.
And they think two is the right number.
So all I,
we,
it,
we had to raise about $300,000
to get on the ballot and then we could
never get enough votes to stay on the
ballot.
So eight times we'd spent all this
money,
all this collection of signatures.
Yeah.
I figured that I could get two percent.
It takes two percent to stay on the
ballot.
We'd never done that.
So if you set your goals really low,
you can be a success.
I got more than two percent,
so I figured I could do that.
An idea that was my objective is to get
the two percent and I got two point
eight percent.
Do you think that some of those ideas
that you are running on 2008 have taken
root in North Carolina?
They were at least mentioned by the
other candidates and sometimes the
newspapers would even point this out
also.
I was in for televised debates and in
some ways I'm their worst nightmare.
I have a phd in economics.
I'm a certain superficial glibness and
no chance of winning so I could answer
the questions.
Yeah,
I haven't got the superficial.
Maybe it'll come or maybe you're very
effective at it and I've,
I've missed it.
Thank you.
What do you think is the reason that the
libertarians haven't done more at the
state level?
When people talk about the libertarians,
they go,
well,
Gary Johnson or whatever it is,
and yes,
there is ramp all but technically he's a
republican.
Absolutely.
There was Justin Amash.
There's a couple people,
but why haven't they done more just on
the local level?
This seems like a major,
uh,
opening for them coming over here.
I was promising myself.
I wasn't gonna answer this question,
but what the heck go crazy.
I'll say here's what happens at
libertarian meetings.
The first one,
20 or 30 people show up and they're all
enthusiastic and at the second meeting
10 people show up and the,
the 10 say,
I'm really glad those others didn't come
back.
They weren't real libertarians because
what they're mainly concerned about is
checking each other's papers.
So you can tell if it's a real
libertarian meeting by how long is it
before there's an argument about whether
individuals should be able to own
nuclear weapons.
Nobody cares about that.
When I was running for governor,
people would say,
would you end the Fed?
Yeah,
I'm running for governor.
Actually this is not set yet,
but I want to know.
So what we really care about is
ideological purity because if you cared
about actual policy or winning,
you would suck it up and be a Democrat
or Republican.
So the problem that we have as
libertarians is that I don't think
people can see themselves as being part
of a political process.
They think of themselves as,
oh,
trey as being outside and truth tellers
that the keepers of last flickering
remnant of truth.
And that's just not a very effective
political strategy.
That's interesting because to me,
after doing this show for about two
years and having,
you know,
a lot of classical liberals on a lot of
libertarians,
and I've had progressives and
conservatives and everything that to me
basically the difference that I see
between classical liberal and
Libertarian is a little more realistic
utility for the state.
So when someone comes in with that
question and says to you,
well,
you're going to get rid of the Fed and
you got running for governor.
And also that's a really high level
philosophical thing that we know that to
me it's just,
it's just a more realistic approach to
how to change things.
Do.
Do you think that's a fair assessment?
Yes,
and I've made a distinction in a couple
of things that I've written between
directional and destination as
Libertarians destination.
This libertarians have a particular
liberty OPA in mind and anything that's
not like that is out.
Analysts would want to say,
are there policies that we could choose
that would be cheaper,
lower deficits,
lower the power of the state,
and increased personal responsibility
and liberty.
So an example would be when I was
running for governor,
my educational platform was vouchers and
a lot of people means tested vouchers.
So the poorest 40 percent would get more
school choice.
Many of the wealthy habit.
Now,
uh,
let's have more school choice for the
very poor and a lot of people on the
left,
we're kind of interested in that.
There's a lot of African American
citizens that are just desperate to get
their school,
their children into better schools.
Libertarians almost without exception
said,
oh no,
the state would be involved in that.
The only acceptable libertarian policy
is the immediate elimination of all
taxes.
Right?
Again,
this is the part that is not the
realistic part because they're direct
their destination lists,
so the destination lists are always
going to be there.
The Libertarians are,
they're going to have any success.
Are gonna have to appeal to the
directionalist in both parties that say,
look,
the government has too many powers.
We may disagree about how far back we
want to move it,
but let's move the train in the other
direction.
We're going the wrong way,
but I think there's a consensus.
We should move it back where we get off
the train.
That's a different question.
Yeah,
but let's change the direction.
What would you say is the easiest way to
explain state power?
A state,
local or federal to the person that
doesn't quite get this to the person
that when you talk about government
power in government or reach,
they don't.
They just think it's like you're talking
about some sort of ephemeral thing that
doesn't really exist.
What do you think the best argument to
get them to start understanding the
ideas of why?
Of what liberty really is?
Well,
this is obviously something I've thought
about a lot and I haven't really
succeeded,
so you're asking what the best argument
it is,
but it's very frustrating because people
have a conception of a thing called a
state,
so something I've written a lot about is
the unicorn conception of the state.
So imagine that I have a,
a mass transit proposal and what we'll
have is these large carts that are
pulled by Unicorns and Unicorns are
great for mass transit because they eat
rainbows.
There are very strong and their
flatulent smells like fresh strawberry,
so there's no emission.
He's not know that part.
It's.
There's no emissions problem.
That's really great.
Now you could object.
Well,
I think there's a problem with this
actually because Unicorns don't really
exist.
Close your eyes.
You see one,
so why they totally exist in the sense
that I can imagine them.
That's how people think of the state.
When I say here's the state is messing
up,
well,
right,
because we are bad people or we need to
do is get the right depth better because
I can imagine a state that's doing these
things.
It's very difficult to fight that.
So the argument that I tried to make,
having given that caveat that it's hard
to fight unicorns because that's what
people want is something they can
imagine,
not something that exists.
Uh,
but the argument that I actually tried
to make is that every flaw in consumers,
and there are many,
is worse in voters.
So you think consumers are too stupid to
be able to choose what size to buy or
which car to buy.
Voters have all those problems and more
so my colleague Dan Arielli at Duke who
writes about rationality and consumer
problems,
uh,
and once the state to intervene,
there's no such thing as the state.
There's just people.
If we're going to have voters choose
what these experts are going to make
people do,
it will be even worse than the market.
Right?
So it's a.
So basically we are the flaw in the
system in a,
in a really perverse way that the best
system is one that recognizes that and
doesn't try to do too much because if we
give voters enough power,
they'll do what they did in the south
and afflict minorities.
They'll,
they'll or they'll say no.
Same sex marriage.
There's no reason to think that if you
take one person who's too stupid to make
his own choices at the grocery store and
put them together into an angry mob,
they can then choose a good precedent or
a good f,
the food and Drug Administration.
So let's talk about that mob for a
second because I sensed that both sides
right now are being led by their mob.
I see it more on the left,
but I do see it on the right as well.
That just the hysterical people who have
all the magical answers who have.
If it was only their messiah.
So the hysterical people on the right,
they have their messiah in office right
now,
but the hysterical people and on the
left that if they only had Bernie,
it would all be okay.
The middle,
it's hard to get that middle of mob to
get going.
Right?
It was very difficult to be deeply
committed to moderation,
so I'm yates has that poem where he says
the worst are full of passionate
intensity,
while the best lack all conviction
because you're thinking,
well,
this is actually hard.
There's a bunch of people that think
it's not hard.
They know exactly what to do and
politics,
if it's gonna work needs to have rules,
institutions,
constitutions that prevent them from
being able to control the government,
and that's the genius of what our
Constitution has done.
That separation of powers.
I understand it's really frustrating
because it means that you feel strongly.
There seems to be majority in favor of
it and yet we still can't do it because
the president doesn't go along.
The Supreme Court doesn't go along.
It means that a lot of times the status
quo is privileged,
but the alternative is to have a mop and
Plato,
when he thought of democracy actually
talked about too much.
Liberty means that you've got the
butlers that are drunk on,
on liberty's heady wide,
right,
and that they'll say if,
if they find a leader who doesn't give
them too much,
they'll,
they'll call them blackbirds and
oligarchs,
that you should do exactly what we want.
Well,
they don't actually know what they want.
So we have a real problem in,
and this is an interesting paradox in
democracy.
Um,
there was a famous Englishman that said
the reason that we put our leaders'
heads on stamps is that we can thumb
their noses and lick their hunter park.
So we have both of those attitudes
towards leaders.
We want them to be better than us and to
do what we say is part of this also,
that we think that we need to get our
morals from our leaders too.
And maybe that's changing a little bit
with trump,
but that we thought that,
you know,
they always want you to.
You're going to be married,
you're gonna,
have the perfect family,
we're going to show you the kids.
We know that it's always a fraud and
they're all cheating on their wives and
doing all sorts of awful things,
but that we've tried to make our
politicians into be perfect humans,
which again is the Messiah thing you're
talking about,
but it's,
it's just,
it's just show.
Sure.
It's difficult.
We have other things,
you know,
there's basketball to watch,
there's,
there's baseball,
there's picnics to go on.
We don't really want to have to watch
politicians very closely and so we
substitute.
I was really surprised at this,
how little voters knew or cared about
actual issues and the issue that I,
as a political scientist,
I want to talk about that,
you know,
they're going to drive.
I got it,
girl.
I'm really not interested in that at
all.
Oh,
but it's an important issue.
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm out.
I'm sorry.
Um,
what they're interested in stead is your
character.
So if your character is very much like
them,
it means that you'll go off and when
they're not watching,
they'll do what they would have done.
You will do what they would've done.
Right?
And so they want you to know are,
are you like me in terms of core values?
And that's why family and things like
that matter is that you're a good
person.
Now,
the problem is that trump is a strange
misnomer in that is any.
He said the things that many white
people believed,
trump won a majority of white women.
I think that's the single most
astonishing fact about this election.
Trump won a majority of white women.
And the reason is that the Democrats,
for reasons that I have a hard time
understanding,
mostly campaigned on a platform of white
people suck.
You guys are privileged,
uh,
you.
And there's all sorts of reasons why
actually you can say that that's true.
But as a political strategy,
it didn't work.
And so Clinton,
when she said,
why,
how am I not ahead by 50 points,
it's amazing that they didn't recognize
that they had actually to appeal to a
majority of Americans,
not to try to put together a coalition
of disparate interest groups that are
united by nothing except the promise
that they're going to get paid off.
So that goes directly to social justice.
Which I talk about all the time,
I assume you see this as a as a pretty
big threat to the way our political
system should work,
right?
It sounds good.
Social injustice,
but in in reality,
it's creating these competing interests
that have to sort of knock each other
down a peg.
We're all in favor of justice and social
justice means that we have a system that
works.
I see social justice as the claim that
there shouldn't be any unearned and to
the extent that people think they've
been denied something,
that's where this social justice warrior
impulse comes from and it's particularly
interesting being on college campuses to
see what social justice warriors have
done where they won't even allow other
people to speak.
So there's A.
There's a broad problem of free speech
and social justice and then the problem
on college campuses that I have to deal
with often personally,
the the social justice warriors and
academic freedom,
which is a little bit different from
free.
Freedom of speech.
Academic freedom is a different concept,
[inaudible],
but the,
the,
the social justice impulse to the extent
that it's a number of people have said,
but I think Milton Friedman said it.
If you take money from a and give it to
be,
it's likely be will vote for you.
That doesn't mean that it's the right
thing to do just campaigning with other
people's money.
And so all of us are clever.
We can come up with reasons why you
should get something and you should get
something in,
you should get something,
but at some point you run out of other
people's money.
Yeah.
And you've just split.
Now this thing into a gajillion things.
So discussing this on,
on the campus front,
um,
how bad is it on campuses right now?
I talked to professors all in all sorts
of different disciplines and almost
everybody says it's pretty terrible.
I'm really spoiled because I'm at Duke.
So I mean you've probably heard about
how bad Charles Murray's visit to duke
was.
Probably didn't because it was fine.
We had Charles Murray in.
Oh wait,
which was the one that got me there,
which was the one that was the whole
thing.
There was a,
uh,
a number of places that Charles Murray
tried.
Oh,
okay.
Okay.
I've turned out really badly.
He came to duke.
There were three idiots with booboos
alien,
and the room was quite.
You couldn't even hear it.
Yeah,
it was fine.
People asked some questions.
In fact,
I asked that they ask more rude
questions.
He's a grownup,
is happy to answer aggressive,
rude questions.
So I think that the answer is I have an
odd view probably.
I'm a big fan of safe spaces.
Yeah.
So you wrote,
I wanted to ask about it.
So you wrote a piece on,
on learn liberty in defensive safe
spaces,
which as I read it,
you parse it to a point that actually
makes some sense to me because I'm not a
safe space guy.
So take it away.
Well,
it's an attempt at judo,
obviously I'm using safe space in a way
where people who were in favor of safe
spaces,
they go,
yeah,
yeah.
Wait,
what?
Right.
So you,
you kind of flip it.
So can you explain to me the main
principle universities are operating on
is not freedom of speech.
We can say anything you want,
but academic freedom,
which means that you can go off into
little groups and be insulated from
people that you disagree with so you can
work on something.
So the political scientists are working
on something in a particular way.
Sociology is working on something in a
particular way.
We have communities of scholars that
work on things and in our talks there's
a bunch of things that are shared
premises,
shared assumptions and we're going to
try to advance without constantly having
to confront all of the other possible
ways of thinking about this.
Right?
So,
so you're describing that as a safe
space.
But I,
I feel like that's not exactly what the,
uh,
like I don't know that many people would
argue that that isn't okay.
Right.
Even the people that are a safe space,
but the,
then we can go on to,
to,
to raise the question.
And Van Jones has this amazing video
where he makes exactly the right
argument.
I think what you cannot do is annex the
entire university as a safe space.
You cannot say,
I want to be all across the university
safe from anything that I disagree with.
So the,
it's the very fact that there's these
different safe spaces that nearly ensure
there's going to be somebody working on
things you totally disagree with and
they have to be safe within that space.
You don't get to,
uh,
prevent them from doing that.
So I think we need safe spaces for
examples for fraternities and that's
the,
you know,
the safe space.
People are near the fraternities,
you know,
people need to be able to come up with
associations.
So there's five freedoms that are
guaranteed in the first amendment and we
forget freedom of association.
Freedom of association means I get to
choose the people that I hang out with
and if I want to have a club or
organization and we have rules and we
want to talk about the stuff,
we want to talk about,
inhibin,
the speakers that we want,
even if it's Milo.
Okay?
But people seem to be lost and confused.
I see.
Even with the guests that we choose
here,
if I choose one person to love me for a
year,
then I put on one person who they don't
like.
Suddenly they they prescribe all of that
person's beliefs onto me.
I go,
well,
I was just asking them questions and and
listening to the answers and you can
either turn it off or maybe you'll learn
something.
So John Stuart mill has this great idea
of education where he says it requires
collision with error and the way I try
to explain it to people is,
and I think this happens much more on
the left,
that a lot of the young students on the
left have just learned one move chess
openings.
They moved upon in front of their king
out two spaces and then their patted on
the head until good liberal and somebody
knows a five move chess opening in
response.
They're really upset.
Can you do that?
Well,
you must be a bad person and in fact
we're going to prevent that because I
don't know why your argument is false.
The only possible explanation is that
it's evil,
is that you're a racist bigot.
Homophobic Saturday because they've
never actually had to confront people
that they disagreed with,
so collision with error means that
you're constantly trying to improve your
own views because if you find someone
you disagree with,
one of two things is true.
Either you are right,
but you don't know the reasons and you
should think about it because not
knowing the reasons is a lot like not
knowing the truth.
Memorizing some catechism of truths is
not what college is about.
It's learning reasons and being able to
reason critically.
You can't do that unless you know the
best argument against your position.
So one of the things that I'm pretty
judgmental about this,
I'll ask people that's an interesting
claim.
What do you think is the best counter
argument to that?
And if they say,
well,
there isn't one we're done,
you don't know anything.
But if they say,
you know,
there's actually two that I have a real
problem with and I think I can answer
them.
But they're interesting arguments.
That person's an intellectual.
Yeah.
It's funny because some of my best
moments you can see the way I interview
with them.
I'm really,
I haven't looked at it the notes once
and I'm trying to hear you and just go
where it feels natural,
but some of my best moments on the show
I think are where someone has pinned me
into thinking,
wait a minute.
I really have to reevaluate something
and I.
and that's how.
That's how you evolve and that's how
most of us are.
And yet we've so that go with that in
the public and I think some of it's
generational.
A lot of the young students just have
never thought about the problem of
having to learn by arguing.
So one of the things that I do in class
and it's it worked better than I thought
was I divide the students into pairs and
they have to choose a question.
They're going to debate.
And then on the day of the debate and
the debates or 30 minutes on the day of
the debate,
both of them hold up big ass yellow dice
because there's not enough ritual in our
lives.
So you have to hold the dice over your
head and you roll it.
And whoever gets the higher role gets to
choose which side that know which side
you're arguing until that moment.
Yeah.
How does that go?
It they love it because they actually.
They pay much more attention now to
things they disagree with because they
wouldn't understand it.
They may have to argue it.
Do you find that sometimes the ones that
are arguing things they don't believe
actually do a better job because of
that,
because they're actually there.
Do they have to do more intellectual
work and they're not so emotional?
Where I have an attachment to a
particular position,
it's hard for me to explain it because I
just know it's right.
Yeah.
Whereas if it's an argument I don't
agree with,
I'm thinking of it logically step by
step and I'm presenting evidence.
So in a lot of times they end up saying,
well,
yeah,
I kind of got to change my mind.
That's not really what I believed after
all.
Or at least I can see why someone would
believed the opposite.
That's what education is.
Yeah.
So it sounds like your situation at Duke
is pretty good and maybe they've.
They've managed to figure out the free
speech thing a little bit better than
most universities.
Duke is really committed to it and the
thing is it's not very hard thing to
commit to.
So our previous president,
Namco hands,
the best college president I've ever
seen,
and there was an incident where David
Horowitz had bought this ad about how
reparations for slavery were racist and
you know,
it was pretty incendiary and I didn't
like the ad.
I thought it was out of line,
but the newspaper,
the Duke Chronicle had allowed the David
Horwitz to purchase a one page ad.
Now he had done that in a number of
newspapers.
You did it at Brown University at Brown
University.
They had a ceremonial burning of the
newspapers on the steps of the admin
building in which the president
participated.
That's horrible.
At Duke,
what Nan Cohan said was,
it's a newspaper.
You want to buy an ad?
Go ahead.
Right.
That's not a very hard position to take.
It's a newspaper.
I might not have taken that as editor.
I'm not editor.
You want to contested by Annette,
so do you think that the students or the
faculty or whatever it was at Brown when
they do that sort of thing,
do you think they realized that they
ultimately strengthen the ideas that
they're going up against?
So for example,
I've had David Horowitz on the show.
I think he's a decent guy.
I agree with them on some stuff,
you know,
he,
he was a former leftist and I think 30
years ago was struggling with a lot of
the issues that I'm thinking about these
days.
Um,
but basically I sat across from him.
I thought he's a decent guy.
I didn't think he was some right wing
maniac or all the things that they say
about him so that when they then,
you know,
burn the newspapers or whatever,
and then now you have people doing a
little research on him and then they may
go,
well,
this isn't all crazy what he's saying.
They'll look at the reaction to him that
all the one alternative would be looking
in the newspaper and said,
oh Geez,
that would be the same.
Wasted all that money because you're not
persuaded by it either though,
boy,
as if people are paying that much
attention to newspaper ads,
you know?
Well,
they did after the administration at
Brown burned it,
that got so much attention.
So if nothing else,
it certainly does validate two claims,
one,
the university is not capable of holding
legitimate discussions or confrontations
with ideas you disagree with.
And the other is,
I'm going to look at this ad and see
what it says because it's pretty
controversial.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
we've got about 50 minutes and we really
haven't done that much on economics.
So I do,
I want to shift a little bit,
um,
because to me it seems that economics,
if we could get the economic system to
work right,
whatever that means,
that it does resolve a lot of the
political things.
Basically if people have jobs and can,
you know,
buy some stuff and feel that they own
property and things of that nature,
that those other things will become less
important.
I,
that's my basic belief.
Do you think that's a fair premise to
start off with?
It's interesting that so many things are
going on at once because uh,
the most recent reason magazine John Nih
at George Mason University has this
brilliant article about inequality.
So it is true that if you look at income
levels,
there's more inequality and the reason
is there's more rich people and the rich
have gained by more than the poor,
but the poor have gained a lot.
So,
but let's compare this to 1800 and 1800.
The mode of transportation of the
wealthy.
It was very different from the poor.
Now,
if I'm really rich,
maybe I have a tesla and you have a
dodge minivan.
Chevy Equinox leased it,
it,
it's not that different really.
It has air conditioning works pretty
well.
It gets the,
of the tesla gets good gas mileage,
but if there's some sort of status
difference,
but,
but we're basically doing the same thing
the same.
Yeah,
we've got an internet connection at
home.
We've got a nice television.
Uh,
we've got a computer,
we've got a laptop,
we've got a cell phone.
There are some differences in status,
but there's never been more equality in
the basic way that people live their
lives and the the difference in if you
look at the difference in life
expectancy between the wealthy and the
port used to be enormous child mortality
rates,
it was enormous.
It's converged.
Our biggest problem is not starvation.
It's obesity,
so there has never been a time of
greater equality.
Now I know some people are going to hear
that and go,
ah,
you libertarians.
What he's saying is you people on the
bottom habit tv,
have a cell phone,
have a.
What about the people that don't have
that stuff?
Now again,
what you're saying though is that most
of the,
the bottom has sort of moved up to have
a decent level,
but what about that other?
What's the libertarian view of how you
help or not help the,
the people that don't have that
baseline?
Two things.
One,
when historians look back at the period
between 1945 and 2010,
the great story is the worldwide
elimination of policy of poverty through
capitalism.
Every country that has chosen markets
has dramatically improved.
Not just the average but the least.
Well off China,
India,
poverty is disappearing around the
world.
If by poverty,
use some objective measure.
If you have a subjective or comparative
measure,
yes,
it's a problem because there's always
going.
There's always going to be one fifth of
the people in the bottom 20 percent.
Just the definition.
I'm not a mathematician,
but I can go.
Yeah,
that.
so that's one thing is the allowing
markets solves poverty in a way that no
government program ever could.
It's better to have a job than a
handout.
On the other hand,
I have written quite a bit about my own
support for universal basic income.
So I think universal basic income is a
better solution than the hodgepodge of
different intrusive programs that we
have now.
And let me explain briefly why.
So what we have is a system,
and I wrote a pretty incendiary paper
about this.
The state is just is a bad polygamist,
so if you're a single mother and you
have three children,
if you do one of two things,
you'll lose your support from the
polygamist if you get a job or get
married.
If you actually do something that
achieved some independence for yourself,
your husband,
the state will,
we'll we're getting a divorce,
right?
I don't care.
I mean you can have more children,
you can have affairs,
but you have to be committed to me.
You can only get support from me,
which means that you can't do any of the
things that normally we would expect.
And this is a conservative position.
I suppose.
Family and jobs are good things.
Being married and having a job as a good
thing,
we have what many people even on the
left have called the cliff effect of a
benefits.
If I'm in section eight,
housing and I,
I get subsidies for food,
I get subsidies for school.
The first $10,000
that I earned costs me $12,000
in benefits.
So the poor aren't lazy.
They're rational.
Right?
So there,
there really,
it's just a realistic gay,
I don't want,
I don't want to say game.
They're not playing a game,
but it's a.
they're making calculations in that
technical sense.
Yes.
The,
they have choices.
They have strategies.
Those have payoffs.
Yeah.
It's unsurprising.
They pick the ones that make them better
off because they're desperate.
They can't afford to lose this money.
So for example,
if you're living in subsidized housing
in a decent area with a decent school,
and even if you don't want those
handouts,
well then you realize,
wow,
I'm gonna have to work in a third job
now and then,
and they're going to force me to move.
I see a much worse place to live.
I can't afford childcare,
so the state is a bad polygamist let's
stop doing that and let's say,
and another problem as I see it as
minimum wage now,
the effects of minimum wage on overall
employment economists debate,
but it's almost certainly true that it's
very difficult for people to get a first
job or require the experience that
allows them to start the staircase to
the American dream.
So the unemployment rate in some urban
areas for like 15 to 25 year old,
so there's 40,
50 percent there.
There's no way for people to find a
first job.
Why do we do that?
While we want to say people should be
able to live on this,
it's not clear why your first job should
be something you should be able to live
on.
Yeah,
and if any,
if you even bring that up,
people get upset.
Well,
except I say,
you know,
you're right.
Let's make sure that they can live.
Let's give them universal basic income
and if they want to get a job at $3 an
hour because that's how you get
experience in Europe.
In Germany,
if you serve an apprenticeship,
you're making two or $3 an hour after
two years you have enough experience,
you can now get a job that makes $30 an
hour.
So it's an education.
So to me,
universal basic income that's given
without strengths.
We take the money that we're spending
now,
which is enough to give at least $12,000
per poor people.
So you take the amount that we spend
divided by the number of where are taken
that from.
Well all of these different subsidy
program to all of the subsidy programs
then go to.
So we including social security.
So we eliminate all those.
Yeah.
Use that money to give everyone a
universal basic income and if they get a
job,
they don't lose it.
If they get married,
They can use it for childcare.
One of the problems that people have now
is it's very specifically tied a
location,
so I can't go somewhere where there's a
job because I won't be able to establish
myself.
Universal basic income if it's federal
means that if I'm living in Cleveland,
Ohio,
I can't find a job.
There are jobs in Texas or North
Carolina.
When I get there,
I get universal basic income.
I can establish myself,
I can pay for childcare,
I can look for a job,
and they actually are jobs in those
places.
Do you find a conflict between your
libertarian self and your economists
self on this because it seems like the
idea of a libertarian going to state
should give people money?
Probably seems like there's some fight
there.
Sure.
If you're a destination list,
if I'm a direction list,
I say,
dude,
we're giving them the money now.
Right?
We're already doing it.
Let's just give the money.
In a way that's cheaper and increases
liberty.
That's the basic directionalist
argument,
which is why Milton Friedman,
Charles Murray are both in favor of
universal basic income,
but it has to be a directionless and
we're already doing that.
Now you're saying,
we shouldn't do that.
Great,
good for you.
We are,
and unless you have some plan to end
that and improve things,
I'll listen to that.
That's not what they say.
They just say,
well,
the government shouldn't be giving out
any money.
It already is.
Let's do it in a more efficient way and
in a way that increases liberty because
I can then spend that money on what I
actually want.
We give these vouchers for food,
which I don't really want to buy that.
I want to buy something else.
I sell my food stamps for fifty cents on
the dollar.
If I get money,
I already have one hundred cents on the
dollar.
Now,
the one objection that people on the
left when people on the left make is,
well,
those poor people,
you know how they are,
they'll spend it on the wrong stuff.
So what I want is that the argument that
people on the,
on the left make,
I think that isn't that usually from the
right where they'll say,
well it's,
they're going to spend it on for some
people,
but a surprising number of people left
belief that.
Yes.
So one of the things I like about this
is it sort of divides the usual
political split by how paternalistic
they are.
There's a whole bunch of people on the
left that really think experts and
honestly rich white people should be
saying here's how these poor people
should be spending their time and money.
Yeah.
Which is probably not.
Well that shows you that a lot about
paternalism and authoritarianism and all
that.
So your next book,
which is called tomorrow,
three point.
Oh,
this is sort of partly what it's going
to be about,
right?
Because that we're going to about to go
into another revolution which is going
to be a shared economy and technological
revolution and that all sort of plays
into,
I suppose basic income and just the way
technology,
you know,
ipads and replacing people at
Mcdonald's.
This is just a fact.
It's interesting,
so Marc Andreessen in November 2011
wrote a piece for the Wall Street
Journal in which he said software eats
the world and what he meant was that
software is to serve as jobs as robots.
Automation are to production,
so we're used to thinking of factories
as being a transformation from a bunch
of people,
putting stuff together to machines,
putting stuff together and it's more
efficient,
but it means there's fewer jobs.
So capitalism almost always reduces jobs
by increasing productivity as a trump
was wrong and saying that we're sending
jobs to China.
The whole world is losing jobs to
productivity and that's good because
consumer products are reduced in price
and it means that we're all wealthier.
The reason that everyone,
almost everyone can afford a car and a
cell phone is that the price of those
things has fallen so much.
Problem is until now we've said,
well,
there's always the service economy.
People can always get service jobs.
They can't.
And that's being hastened by the push
for increased minimum wages.
So in Seattle,
for example,
if you have a fast food restaurant,
you're probably investigating kiosks.
So you don't have to pay $15 an hour to
have some guy who really isn't worth $15
an hour at the front desk.
Right.
So the the service jobs are going to be
taken over by software.
It's not clear to me that we're going to
be able to take people who are not
sufficiently well trained by the state
education system to be able to work in
the new economy to make that transition
very quickly.
So I think universal basic income,
you can make a static argument.
We're spending the money already so we
might as well spend it more efficiently.
But then there's a dynamic argument to
over time the move to the sharing
economy probably benefits most of us
because we can rent rather than own a
prices are going to fall dramatically.
We'll need a lot less stuff.
The sharing economy,
just just so people,
for the people that don't fully get it.
So basically that you wouldn't even have
to necessarily own your car.
That all of the.
All of the things that we kind of have
wood,
we'd figure out better ways to use them.
So you wouldn't have to fork out as much
money for them in the first place and
we'd figure out,
well I'm going to use it on Tuesdays at
this time and you're going to use it
then and the exam that.
Is that the base?
Sure.
The example that I always use and I
think people recognize it,
is I have a black BMW 3:30
and I'm just the sort of person you
think I am,
that drives a black BMW 3:30.
I zooming in and out.
It's a very expensive car.
I park it at a special shrine at my
house and I approach it.
The door opens now it's a garage,
but that's pretty expensive storage and
since I worked as an administrator at
Duke for a long time,
I have the parking space of God.
Yeah,
I can park in a great space.
So my car is really expensive and it's
always taking up two pieces of real
estate,
the garage and my parking space at Duke,
which is reserved for me.
When you multiply that by the.
I drive my car 30 slash 40 minutes a
week.
All the rest of the time it's just
sitting there.
I think what's going to happen 50 years
from now is that people are going to
look back and be astonished at the
extent to which we were so selfish that
we wanted to keep stuff so other people
couldn't use it and spend a lot of money
storing it so other people couldn't use
it.
Now,
to some extent that gives us status.
I'm an old guy.
I probably have pictures of my pathetic
car on facebook.
Okay.
Young people don't do that.
They're more interested in accumulating
experiences than they are stuff,
so I think that there's a cultural shift
towards a sympathy towards not having
such a big impact on the environment,
reducing your footprint.
So if a car is constantly in use instead
of sitting in my garage or a parking
space all the time,
we'll need far fewer of them will be
able to have bike lanes because we won't
need to have all this parking space.
We won't need to have closets or storage
units where we have all this crap that
we don't even need.
Storage units are pretty amazing.
We have all of this stuff that you're
not using it and you never go there.
Well it,
but somebody else could be using it.
The reason that they're not using it is
that it's too difficult for you to find
that other person software is going to
change our ability to find someone to
share it with.
Do you find a little bit that that can
be at odds with a individualism that
you're.
You're not saying that you wouldn't have
the right to own things right in,
that's not the end conclusion.
Most people I think want the use of
something and in our current system,
owning it is the cheapest way to have
something available to use,
but it's fairly common for.
I don't.
I have a Tuxedo.
I don't wear it very often.
Um,
many women have gowns that they wear
maybe once now.
The reason that they don't rent the gown
is that it's too difficult to find it in
exactly their size,
but suppose you had an app that could
take computer,
laser measurements and get exactly the
right measurement and it's delivered to
you two days from now and instead of an
$800 gown that you wear once it's $100
rental and it's a designer gown.
That would be great.
Yeah,
so everything's changing I think is the
theme of this hour.
There's a lot changing politically.
There's a lot changing economically and
we just gotta be smart enough to
hopefully not go totally off the ditch
as we're navigating it.
I'm.
I'm mostly optimistic because I think
our institutions are pretty strong and
people recognize that there's a problem.
The social media,
the Internet,
access to software all create
disruptions,
but when you look at human history,
a lot of the best things have happened
after a period of disruption,
but the period of disruption can be
pretty bad.
The 18,
forties and fifties in Europe,
cities were on fire because of the
industrial revolution.
The result was mostly good,
so the.
It's not clear to me what's going to
happen,
which again,
is one of the reasons I'm for universal
basic income.
Let's make sure that those who are least
well off and who are through no fault of
their find
themselves not able to work in the
traditional manufacturing jobs that they
expected to be there.
Let's make sure that there's some
minimum on how,
on how bad off they are.
Yeah.
It said,
I love the framing of that because it
really is an argument that transcends
the left right thing because you're,
you're hitting them both at their soft
spots.
So it's got a nice,
uh,
a nice ability to get some people to
come together where we'll see that's an
issue for more Dr Monger.
Follow him on twitter.
Maybe I'll respond.
Right?
Oh,
you,
you do respond.
So then you wrote a nice piece on learn
liberty about how when every now and
again you have an experience that
actually changes.
And I'm positive.
There you go,
uh,
follow Dr Mugler on twitter.
It's at Mongo.